what is going on everybody welcome to
part 15 of the AI in starcraft 2 with
python tutorial series in this part what
we're going to be doing is going over
some of the choice changes that we'd
like to make so the previous AI while it
learned some stuff it wasn't going to be
an impressive AI because it only made
like four different choices it only
really controlled whether or not it
wanted to attack and like where did it
want to send all of its units I think it
would be cooler to have an AI that
determines things like buildings to
build which units to produce as well as
attacking so that's the change that
we're going to go ahead and implement
here is an AI that makes more advanced
types of choices and hopefully we can
get that to Train so let's go ahead and
hop into it so the first thing I'm going
to do and again just like I've said
before there's really no new concept
here so I'm gonna just copy and paste
and just kind of go over the changes
that I've I've made so definitely check
out the text-based version of this
tutorial if you want to follow along and
copy and paste with me also the fold to
know the full code is at the end so you
really don't even have to do that
so first change is I'm adding in these
self dot choices so now this AI is gonna
be able to make like up to fourteen
different choices so whether or not to
build the Scout if a Scout exists in its
idle it's not doing anything it's just
gonna automatically Scout I can't
imagine many scenarios where you like
have a scout and not do anything with it
so I'm gonna go ahead and just assume
that we want to scout if we have one
maybe there's a strategy I don't know
about to like have an idol scout but
can't imagine why otherwise build zealot
gateway void race talker assimilators
stargates pylons and then the various
attacks expand and then do nothing so
those are the choices that we're gonna
be willing to make now coming down to
the on step method there's not really
much more we need to do we do want to
keep the Intel method we don't need to
do any of these we do want to distribute
workers we do want to Scout we don't
need to build the Scout anymore so now
you should have Scout distribute workers
Intel and then we're gonna add
one more thing which is just to a weight
do something now that do something
method is what is going to determine
which of those 14 things that we want to
do I'm also gonna put distribute workers
above Scout I I think that probably
makes the most sense or maybe if you
distribute workers under dues and yeah I
have some prior or yeah prior knowledge
coming into this one I don't know I
might want to adjust that later anyway
I'll keep it the way I did it before but
the adjustment there might actually
might make a little bit more sense
because I later on I have some problems
with workers not actually being assigned
a task so it'd be nice if we could find
an I don't want to do something first
and then distribute them and have them
do some work anyways not important at
the moment so now we want to have this
do something method so I'm gonna add
that in as well as just kind of replace
the attack method where is that here it
is paste that in so if the time is after
the do something after if we're using a
model we'll make the prediction based on
the model and actually this probably
needs to be changed to one channel now
we'll fix that later anyways but we're
now otherwise we just make a random
choice and then we await self-taught
choices whatever that choice is
parenthesis so we rerun that method so
that's self dot choices is that first
thing that we added in right here so
it's gonna run that method or it's gonna
call that method to run
thank you sir anyway loud car in case
you didn't hear that sometimes like I
hear stuff and I feel like it's
definitely been picked up on the video
and then it doesn't get picked up anyway
so we've now we've got the do something
and then basically we need to make sure
all of these methods now exist and do
the thing that we want them to do
there's really nothing fancy here if you
want you can go to the text-based
version again and look at them we can
kind of scroll through and talk about a
couple of things but for now I'm going
to all control V and paste and all of
the code so basically you know we're
just going to do the things so so like
with build zealot if we have a gateway
we'll build it the only thing I kind of
wanted to tinker with is like what if we
the option where the choices build
zealot what if we don't have a gateway
should we if the decision is to build a
zealot should we just assume that like
if we don't have a gateway and we try to
build a zealot let's build a gateway at
least maybe I'm not really sure because
build gateway is one of the choices so
wouldn't the AI be a little more robust
if it knew no no no I need to build a
gateway right now but I'm not really
sure because the AI doesn't yeah I
doesn't really have any knowledge of
like how many gateways does it have
which is why I kind of wanted to color
things differently which I still might
do in the future because how else would
it know do I have that cybernetics core
or whatever so that's kind of difficult
to figure out there's so many more so
like you know when we had just like the
four choices there's just not as many
variables to consider into tweak but now
that we have 14 choices there's like so
many little things that we have to start
considering to try to make this AI work
but anyway let's go ahead and run this
real quickly make sure everything works
Oh hmm so I just recently installed
Python 3.7
that's not going to work with pious situ
so what we're gonna have to do is run
let me pull just a command prompt and
let's go to Python 36 Python and then
this is part 15 choice changes dot pi
let's run it there I'll stick it down
here really pull this down so I don't
block the resources and while we wait
shout-out to my recent sponsors Delia
white Never Dies cyber carp and Gaurav
Gupta thank you guys very much for your
support and looks like we are off and
running making random choices I'm super
up there it looks like we're now
building the assimilators we got a pylon
coming up I'm gonna move this out of the
way root quick I'm gonna go down to the
bottom and what are we okay we're
difficulty media mning so we're probably
not gonna do very well but we have
inning and expansion anyways I'm just
partly curious how we do looks like they
found our Scout they didn't like him
very much there goes another or that's a
worker okay what he is going to scout
I have not witnessed this a I ever beat
anything but the easy I'm just curious
to see if maybe this time it'll be a
medium I don't think it will but it
looks like we're playing pretty well
right now but well we do have a gateway
but that's about it right now we should
be producing way more workers probably
we got a cybernetics core up good is
that our second gateway I think that's
our second gateway now yep warping in a
I didn't quite catch what that was
oh we actually have quite a few units
Wow three zealots somehow someone did
not appreciate my zealot it is properly
pronounced zealot but I'm gonna keep
calling it a zealot it's kind of like
epic versus epoch
it's just thing you're gonna have to
deal with that but they don't last very
long mm-hmm they're going down they're
done hey but we got some more send him
in I think they already on their way
actually oh hey we got a stalker now
well done well done and we're warping in
another stalker
ah we're under attack now though what do
they have looks like they got to who's
of these things that all those are
there's you know it's not gonna end well
here and who is this worker hmm
oh man our our dudes dead yeah this is
definitely a game over situation at this
point okay
so I'll give it up so no no victory
there for sure
really we're just not producing enough
workers it'd be nicer if we produced
many many more workers at this point so
we can talk in a future video
on how how we're gonna adjust for that
but I think I'll break it here and the
next thing I want to start talking about
is the visualization of the game right
now we have three channels and we
probably don't need three channels we're
also not visualizing everything that we
could were visualizing ourselves a
different way and also since we've got
many different units we're not
visualizing all the units that we even
were producing so we have to make a fix
for that so anyways that's what we're
gonna be doing in the next tutorial if
you've got questions comments
suggestions for improvement whatever
feel free to leave them below otherwise
I will see you all in the next video